&gt;&gt; These three equations all graph parabolas. Even though they might not quite
look like it right now. With a little bit of rearranging though, all of these
can be put into that general form for the equation of a parabola. Which you'll
remember, is y equals a x squared plus b x plus c, where a is not equal to zero.
Now this first equation, 3 x squared plus 3 x minus 7 equals zero, does not
contain a y variable. The only variable it has is x. So this is just an equation
that we can solve for x. But it's not something that we can plot. There's no
information here about y that would let us graph on a coordinate plane. Or at
least, not on the kind of coordinate plane that we've been interested in. With
two variables. This equation actually already is in standard form. The y just
happens to be on the right side, and the other expression on the left side. But
you can see that A, equals negative 1. B, the second coefficient is 5, and C is
negative 6. This one is also in standard form. We have A equals 1, B equals 0,
and C equals 1. However, the only requirement we have, about general form Was
that a couldn't be 0. Either of the other two constants can be and will still
get a parabola, I'll show you the graphs for all of these in a second. But first
let's look at this last equation briefly. The only thing that is preventing it
from being in this general form is the negative sign in front of the y. If we
just multiplied both sides of the equation, by negative 1 and rearrange the
terms on the right hand side, we end up with an equation of a parabola in the
form of. We can recognize. Y equals X squared minus 2X plus 1. Now let's pick up
these graphs. This third parabola down here is produced by tehe equation y
equals negative x squared plus 5X minus 6. This purple corresponds to Y equals X
squared plus one. And the orangeish yellow one of y equals x squared minus 2x
plus 1. Now just take a second here and think about what's different about these
graphs and what's different about their equations. Just form some ideas in your
head and keep them in mind for later. We'll keep revisiting a lot of different
kinds of parabolas. And of course the differences in their equations that
produce them.